nobody's untouched by this war and its
effects will last for generations we're
less than seven miles from russia's
tanks and artillery but these boys are
out every day protecting their village
but what's left of it with their own
checkpoint and toy guns
their leader is ten-year-old nazar
with great bravado he tells me he's not
scared anymore
he's got used to the shelling and the
killing
think about how shocking that actually
is he's 10.
um
[Music]
foreign
confides in us that passing cars are
stopped and drivers ask to say two
ukrainian words words that are difficult
to say in russian
you couldn't make this up it actually
happened
we've come to the liberated villages to
the north east of kharkiv ukraine's
second largest city to join the search
for dead russian soldiers
in charge of this strange body hunter
troop is vadim a professional soldier
with him are two military volunteers and
a pair of brothers
famed in these parts for their ability
to find bodies
so far the team's team have recovered 80
russian soldiers and 20 civilians the
police take charge of the civilian dead
the brothers have found 16 on their own
it's a macabre job but the team insists
it's important
they find nothing here so the troop move
on they're dependent on local people
reporting strong smells or suspicious
behavior by the russians when they were
here
svetlana takes us to the edge of her
farm
and points to a hillside the russians
used as a base
she said diggers were constantly working
though
it could be a mass grave
she tells us the way to the russian
position is mind
it's a constant problem for vadim and
his team
we have to go round we heard quite a lot
um
over these
last months of uh
russians digging
mass graves for their own soldiers
uh there's a variety of reasons for that
of course but
one is them is to actually control
the news that in fact the invasion was
going so badly and so many men
were being killed remember russia still
doesn't call it a war
the troop searched the base but it's
clear
however has spotted another russian
position and in the woods the body of
one of their soldiers there could be
more
so now you have the body what uh what
will you do
um
[Music]
the war is far from over and it could
easily return here the shelling
continues unabated
many significant dates have come and
gone
the only date that really matters here
is the one when the war is over
still ramsey sky news in northeast
ukraine